[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday june 28th i'm julie chang for
the wall street journal filling in for
zoe thomas
so-called algorithmic stable coins are
supposed to keep at a value of one
dollar unlike regular stable coins which
are backed by actual funds or assets
algorithmic ones use other cryptos to
maintain their peg
but one stablecoin tara usd imploded
last month as the crypto sector as a
whole nosedived terra usd is currently
valued at pennies and the collapse of
terra usd and luna cost investors some
40 billion dollars
now the man who created the kryptos is
trying again
south korean entrepreneur dokwan has
relaunched luna the crypto that was
being used to keep terra usd pegged to a
dollar but what's different this time
around wsj reporter alexander osiepovich
has been following the story and he
joins us now hi alex thank you for
coming back on the show hi julie thanks
for having me
so can you start us off with a little
bit of background who is dokwan and what
is he like do kwan is a south korean
cryptocurrency entrepreneur
for a few years he was very vocal in
building out
a family of cryptocurrencies that all
had the names tara and luna involved in
them and he started a company called
terraform labs that was the main
company that developed projects related
to all of this dokwan uh was very
outspoken on twitter he talked a lot
about how his cryptocurrencies were
going to sort of take over the world and
was very good about drumming up business
basically at least until may when it all
collapsed
so we had you on the show before to help
cover algorithmic stable coins stable
coins or cryptos pegged to the us dollar
algorithmic stable coins used another
crypto to maintain their value instead
of actual dollars or other real assets
in this case it was luna
what went wrong with terra usd and luna
so the idea was if terra usd would drop
below a dollar you could make money by
swapping it for a dollars worth of luna
or if terra usd for some reason went
above a dollar you could swap a one
dollar worth of luna for you know a one
tara usd and make money that way
and that actually worked surprisingly
well for a long time in keeping terry
usd at the price of one dollar
but the whole mechanism was dependent on
the idea that people would actually want
luna that luna would have some value and
that people
would consider it sort of a legitimate
useful backing for terra usd
what happened in may was that during a
period of volatility in the crypto
markets tara usd lost its peg it dropped
below one dollar at first it would drop
down to you know 98 cents or so then it
dropped down to 91 90 cents they tried
to make it recover a couple of times
there was a reserve fund in place where
dokwan and his team essentially sold
bitcoin and tried to prop up the price
of tara usd but they burned through this
pretty fast and the whole thing
collapsed
now both terra usd and luna are
essentially worthless this wiped out
around 40 billion dollars worth of value
so then what's happened to dokwan since
luna crashed
do kwan is hanging tight
he has been facing an investigation in
his native south korea a lot of
investors complained that he had
committed fraud and illegal fundraising
and south korea prosecutors in seoul
told us that they were investigating
he is also facing a lawsuit in the
united states where an investor filed a
lawsuit in california seeking class
action status which made similar
allegations to what the south korean
investors said
terraform labs told us that they would
not comment on any active investigations
as far as a lawsuit goes
terraform labs dokwan's company told us
that would fight the lawsuit in court
they described it as meritless
we should know dokwan has denied that he
defrauded anyone that he had the support
of various big players in the crypto
industry and that he lost money in the
crash himself
and now in the last few weeks dokuan
came out with a new version of luna can
you tell us more about that and what
happens to people's old luna or terra
usds
yes so dokwan is essentially attempting
a reboot
he argues that the kind of system that
he created which is based on something
called the terra blockchain is useful
and has other good things about it
besides this algorithmic stablecoin
which crashed and it is worth noting
that the terra blockchain has these
other projects based on it sort of
lending and trading protocols kind of
like apps that you can build on top of
that operating system as a way to think
about it
so at the end of may they created a
brand new version of the terra
blockchain and they created a new
cryptocurrency which is also called luna
and people who held the old worthless
versions of luna and terra usd were
given the units of the new luna the old
luna was renamed luna classic
and people in sort of a way of
compensation sort of a way to get
activity going in this new blockchain
system
people were given units of the new luna
and there was this whole complex formula
that was behind this but basically they
decided to allocate the new version of
luna to people who had held the old
cryptocurrencies
using a sort of formula based on how
much you held before the crash how much
you held after the crash and so on
but the new luna it began training in
late may and it's already lost a lot of
its value right
yes uh it debuted at almost nineteen
dollars per coin and immediately
collapsed lately it's been trading
around two dollars per coin
basically it appears that a lot of
people were given this and immediately
dumped it and fled to some sort of safer
assets or maybe even to real money so
what do dokwan's critics say about him
launching a new luna
dokuan has a lot of critics people felt
that he did too aggressive a sales job
on his previous
project and essentially shield tara usd
and luna too hard
and they think it's kind of crazy that
he's trying to begin again there's
really nothing stopping him from doing
that in crypto it's an unregulated
market so he has just started over again
and is trying to drum up interest and in
your story you mentioned that dokwan is
a pretty polarizing figure which means
he also has his supporters so why do he
and his supporters think that this is
going to work a second time around
yes he has a community of supporters uh
they call themselves lunatics after the
luna cryptocurrency
and at least some of them are believers
and they think that luna will have a
second coming and they will be able to
make money as the new project rises
dokwan himself says that there is a
community of people who were built
around the terra blockchain people who
were developing different apps trading
on it and who were sort of bought into
its prospect as a technology platform
and he says that as long as there's more
activity on the new terra blockchain
eventually luna will rise again and
there will be other things on it so far
there is no plan to launch an
algorithmic stablecoin on the new
terra blockchain i think if people did
that then there would be some worries
about history repeating itself
all right that was our reporter
alexander ossopovich alex thank you
again for coming on the show thanks for
having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm julie chang for the wall street
journal thanks for listening
[Music]
you